i got in contact with the girl and i
found out that they had slept with each
other back in july
you're stupid to cheat on gina because
she will find out and she will find out
all the details and information of
everyone that this person's ever been
with
[Music]
hello and welcome to the next episode
the new episode the most recent episode
next episode
of big mood podcast hi
i'm back she didn't have kovacs i know
she didn't even have to miss all those
episodes yeah but
she just like she knew that distance
makes the heart grow fonder it's true
and it's speaking of distance we've been
it's been a while so now we had our
guest right now so who do we have here
today for those listeners and not
watchers hello everybody my name is
stacia zapolaka and i'm back and you're
it feels good to back
back
there's all these like old school
songs are popping up like i know the
next episode guess who's back
i'm nikki and i'm gina and it's true
this past week i made it a point to
remember all the words to uh forgot
about joy you do it right out of me do
it right now no it's too early in the
morning i only got the third verse down
the second verse to the same yeah
yeah but i've been low-key hated on by
all these yes people yes
yeah yes
and today we're doing just a quick
catch-up episode we were missing a few
friends today because life is happening
and so we uh it's just us three but
we're gonna catch up on all three of our
lives there's things going on there's
everyone's lives are changing and going
crazy so um casey said we're allowed to
say why why we're missing some people oh
we're allowed to say now the biggest
catch-up of today
is the person that's not even here come
see it casey come say it
[Applause]
sorry if you're wearing headphones and
we just yelled in your ear our friends
are out just creating new friends to
hang out with instead of being with us i
think it's kind of rude it's pretty
really tiff's not here it's selfish
she's only known that paper for you too
yeah and i'm taller than it is i know am
i more funnier
we can talk yeah we can talk we can eat
solid foods we can hold our head up
stupid baby whatever learn some skills
baby i know
god useless right now
um and you guys have already said the
name by now do they would they know
everything by now wait i don't know the
name
oh you say lukaku
this was so
like secretive the whole time i was like
wow they are such youtubers like they're
literally keeping everything in until
the last minute but that's a beautiful
name i love it
i love it and we actually didn't know
though because we
kept this thing to ourselves too they
didn't know the gender and they didn't
know the name until like until the last
minute because even when they had the
baby which by the way was a month early
tiff was supposed to be here today but
she had her baby decided
other plans yeah luca decided other
plans and then when they had the baby um
they sent us all the picture and we're
like what's the name and they're like we
don't know yeah yeah
you don't have a name idk what's his
official birthday what day was he born
january 31st the 31st my theory is that
tiff only has january babies and her
body's like
february so baby didn't wait till lunar
new year that means what what
he's an ox
oh yeah yeah my aunt
like in hong kong she's like buying all
the little
things for like tiger babies yeah
the day before
he's an ox he's like i'm like he's
stubborn if you guys like us
if you guys can't hear uh casey says
they were anticipating a tiger baby so
his aunt in hong kong was buying all
this cute tiger stuff uh but he's a
stubborn as an ox and he came out and
he's that little stupid tiger that
screams a lot with my cat that you guys
probably in the background i am a tiger
oh okay yeah so i was really hoping that
you know what this is the second baby
that's ripped me off because my friend
had the same thing where she had a baby
a month early and we were supposed to be
birthday twins it was supposed to be a
scorpio and it now it's a freaking libra
yeah and then this freaking baby is
supposed to be a tiger we were gonna
like be best friends and he's like nah
i'm gonna be a knox
so what's the other zodiac sign for luca
then
uh
no aquarius yeah she's an aquarius what
they'll make
we love aquarius they're very friendly
it's a good one yeah very good one yeah
very good with people no sure yeah
so great i have no idea oh i have no
idea
yeah i'm gonna query his racing oh so i
mean that's good for reasons women
aquariuses are dope yeah yeah i just
feel every time when people say like oh
it's the women that are good i'm like
it's just all
men yeah are bad true like all
sagittarius men i get along so well with
aries and leah women but then i'm like i
can't stand you yeah i think it's just a
man
period
so uh let's start with our guest you
know update us on your livestream
oh my gosh yeah okay with our cute nails
thank you you're planning your wedding
right it's coming up my wedding is
coming up
soon dude are you freaking out so yes
we're freaking out because i thought we
gave ourselves enough time
but i don't know when you're engaged
time just moves faster than everybody
else's time i know right it totally does
i know what that feels like yeah
it's crazy and so like at the beginning
you'll get there you'll get there at the
beginning we were like oh we have enough
time but then the holidays came and i
danny and i decided to take a little bit
of time off of like the stress of the
wedding and we're like let's just enjoy
the holidays and so after the holidays
it kind of feels like okay it's go time
we have to
move and do everything now um so yeah
it's going by really fast uh weddings
are hella expensive
everything yeah everything so you're
like it's a birthday they're like oh
it's 500 it's a wedding it's twenty
thousand dollars yeah that's crazy wild
like i mean thankfully like i feel like
because we do have this job people are
willing to be like oh yeah like just put
me in the youtube video and like or say
that i did this for you and i'm willing
to give you a discount so i'm like okay
thank god
we're able to do that you know i just
can't imagine
otherwise you know um and so
i we're trying to go about it like this
is the only time we're gonna get married
so we're trying to make it as like
fun and exciting for both of us and for
our family and stuff while also still
trying to remember that it's for us you
know like at the end of the day if
people are like like for example the
food you know normally you would eat
like i don't know steak chicken when you
go to a wedding we're having like
barbacoa which is like mexican play you
guys are going to be eating rinds and
beans
with chips and salsa like
buffet style no no no they're going to
be serving you so we got servers i
honestly prefer that yeah i mean it just
was like sorry but it's what it is you
know and
so we're gonna have like tacos after
yeah so like if you guys drink we're
gonna have like oh my god you're gonna
sober up you know you're gonna have your
little tacos so it's gonna be a good
time and we're staying true to us and to
our culture that's the most important
yeah and so we're we're really excited
i'm a little nervous and thankfully i
found somebody that is gonna be um there
the day of the wedding like uh what is
it called the coordinator coordinator
yeah yeah so coordinating it which is
you need that a huge blessing girl like
god says that was the biggest blessing
that could have happened to us because
he actually does like events and so we
reached out to him to decorate our event
and he does like for a bunch of like um
latino influencers uh because he's
brothers with two girls that are twins
but anyway so i reached out to him and
he said he's like i'm gonna gift you
being the coordinator
awesome oh my god that's like a huge
relief yes i just was like you're
amazing thank you so much i will shout
you out and everything i ever i mean
yeah everything i'm ever in for those of
you who don't know because so my wedding
was the first wedding i ever went to in
my adult life so i didn't know what to
expect they told me i was the chillest
bride ever because i just like had no
expectations at all but i didn't know
that you needed all these things and
someone thank god told me like
definitely invest in a wedding
coordinator invest in the photography
and the wedding coordinator those are
like the top two to like put your money
towards because like on the day
everyone's asking you for [ __ ]
everything like you're like i'm the
bride like stop asking me for shooting
me alone like i'm like i'm already in my
head about stuff but like everybody's
asking [ __ ] and so with the wedding
coordinator you just go here's the
wedding coordinator's number you ask
them all the questions and they just
fueled everything that's you know all
the vendors like where do we set up blah
blah blah no you don't have to think
about it yeah so i we definitely feel
very blessed that he's doing that for us
so that's what's happening and then also
recently we moved in together because we
bought a house congratulations
that's awesome here in l.a uh yes
okay yeah so we did get a house and that
was
incredible i'm grateful to god because
yeah first generation like i'm the first
person to own a home
and or we're the first people to well
his family already has homes in the u.s
but like my family we don't that's
awesome and so it does feel incredible
it's huge [ __ ] yeah especially in this
market it's so hard to like even get
your offer excited it was it was like 18
offers after but yeah
that's amazing it was the perfect house
for us and so like moving in with your
significant other is
so different yes
like i genuinely thought like we he
stays over all the time like i already
don't live at home so he would come over
all the time and like no girl it's
different it's so different and like in
a good way you know it's a learning
curve i feel yeah um it makes me love
him more and i feel that connection
before like i really love him
like we're fiances we love each other
blah blah no when you live together
you're like completely different there's
no score like you literally can do
everything and you you want to do things
yeah i mean at least i feel that like i
want to do things for him and i want to
make sure he feels taken care of and i
want to make sure that he feels loved
through my actions you know it's [ __ ]
crazy i create attitude
because i thought you were going to talk
about how like all the annoying [ __ ]
that you did that they were able to hide
it all comes out well i mean i'm sure
some people have that experience yeah
right but
i feel like a lot of the things feel
more like
i don't know man i'm in love yeah see if
you have that everything else is like
whatever uh like you could work you
could fix the other stuff like yeah okay
it really annoys me that you keep the
toothpaste cap off the toothpaste like
you can put it back on yeah and i mean
it's not rainbows and butterflies of
course there's annoying things and
there's been like kind of like whoa you
do that and like well you do that you
know but
i feel like thankfully i have a partner
who's very understanding and willing to
talk yeah and willing to at least be
like
okay i don't know why this bothers you
but i'm here i'm willing to hear you out
and not do it because it bothers you and
the other way right that's respect
that's awesome
the compromise that those things like as
long as you have a partner that does
that in good communication
that's like the best foundation i mean
you guys have known me since i started
dating day yeah so it definitely has
gradually gotten stronger for sure like
i mean i loved him when i met him of
course but now i'm like i [ __ ] love
this man yeah and like i am willing to
do not everything but i'm willing to do
whatever it takes to make this
relationship work because in the
beginning weren't you kind of like um
i'm not sure if i ever want to get
married yeah yeah yeah not to him but
just like just in general yeah i was
like i just don't know what the point of
marriage is you know and now i get the
point of marriage yeah and now i'm like
yeah like i love him and i want to tie
with him or you know all those things
build like a you like you're like a
unified item and you're building a life
like as one and even outside of my
relationship i think i discovered the
importance of marriage like even if i
wasn't with him
i get it you know i get it now like
before when i was i mean it's crazy it
was what i've known you guys for three
years yeah and it feels longer so much
i mean i feel like i met you guys when i
started like maybe four years so many
things have i think feel like life and
growth and change like that it just
feels longer yeah and then i also met
you guys through um jk no no what is it
called the
the
the retrograde in your 30s oh right what
is it called i forget what it's called
my saturn return i met you guys yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah basically what it is it's like
everything like everybody goes to their
saturn return from like 27 to 30 where
you go from being like a quote-unquote
like kid to like an adult right so life
throws big things at you so for example
in my life i'm getting married i'm gonna
i we bought a house um just big life
changes that have made me grow and so
when i first met you guys i think i was
going into that yeah and now i'm deep in
it that's so funny i didn't know what
had a name i actually didn't know that
because i've always said like after 26
is when you become who you really are
yeah like before 26 it's like practice
but after that and you and i even strong
willed like i thought i knew who i was
like i thought
no i don't think i'm gonna change that
much no no after [ __ ] 26 you become a
the person that you are yeah as an adult
yeah significantly yeah so different
yeah so i feel like i mean a lot about a
lot of things have changed and even my
mentality has changed
um but yeah i mean that's where i'm at
right now in life
and it's a it's a really amazing place
to be i'm very grateful for great i'm so
glad also no shade to anyone that still
doesn't see the point of marriage like i
i know there's like
there's a lot of different reasons for
different feelings and all that but
you know i used to kind of feel that the
same way not that i didn't want to get
married i always wanted to get married
to my person but um
i just didn't think that it was gonna
feel different i was like okay well this
is just on paper you know finalizing it
because i want to build a family
together but i don't um i don't really
think anything's gonna change feelings
wise yeah and it actually
i don't know why but it made it so much
stronger and i didn't even think it
could get stronger but you really do
feel like a team like uh
you're building something like you guys
are in it together like this is your
family now yeah it does feel like that i
mean it's even like a little bit sad not
sad but it's a little bit sentimental to
let go of like the boyfriend girlfriend
face
that you know you're like it's kind of
feels like kid's love that we're now
grown into our relationship and like
we're no longer just like oh boyfriend
girlfriend like we're just holding him
yeah like no it's like we're business
you know i'm wearing his shirt yeah
yeah and so like definitely enjoy each
face of your relationship because it
will come and go and every face has its
beautiful things you know but you look
back and like that's why i'm like trying
to soak up everything about being a
female yeah like i'm just like wearing
the bright shirts and wearing the mickey
my favorite ears i wish like i wish that
lasted the bridesmaid yeah i mean you
could make it last as long as possible
just saying fiance took a while to get
used to yeah but then once you get used
to it it's really hard to say husband
yeah i mean but yeah it's a really happy
time right now we're really happy that's
awesome i'm so happy for you
how does he how is he feeling is he like
nervous or anything so i feel like danny
is like a really
like when he's nervous or stressed out
he kind of doesn't like to say it out
loud because i feel like as the
like masculine energy in our
relationship he's kind of like i have to
keep it together you know and i have to
protect or whatever and so when we first
moved in together i was like how do you
feel and he was like i feel like i'm
responsible for you now
that's good yeah yeah it's cute and so
he's like if i hear noises outside you
we need to get security cameras like he
sleeps with like um uh the lamp next to
his his bed like his side of the bed and
so it's even amazing to watch him come
into that yeah because he's younger than
me i'm three years older and so when i
met denny he was 24. wow yeah and so
when i look back i'm like oh my god
yeah a child you know but
now watching him become a senior like
that's what it feels like i'm like he's
like a senior now yeah
yeah like so he has like his own house
and like
it's like it is it's adorable and even
like watching him
rise up to the occasion of being like i
have to work and i have to do this and
like here's money for groceries and
here's the provider [ __ ] yeah i'm like
yeah i love it i love you this way you
know i
love watching him become a husband yeah
in front of my eyes
um it's really attractive it makes me
fall in love with him more you know and
it's like
yes
go on yeah yes protector
like i love it so much and i i'm very
grateful and of course we all have our
learning curve you know like i'm also
becoming
like a wife you know i've never cooked
so much in my life
i didn't cook yeah i didn't cook but now
that we live together of course it's
more affordable to cook at home and so
here i am making and figuring out you
got a mortgage now you gotta cook you
gotta get groceries yeah and so like
like learning and looking up recipes and
asking my mom how do you do this how do
you do that um i cleaned so [ __ ] much
now i've never really told you in my
life
uh but it feels it feels good like i
don't know you it maybe some people are
gonna be like oh my god like girl we get
it but it just feels really nice to
be like a wife and trainee yeah like i
always grew up being like i need to be a
go-getter i need to be independent i
need to get make money and so now to
kind of step back and be like
i'm gonna be a homemaker and i'm going
to make this home beautiful but it
doesn't mean you lose that part of you
it's just that like okay i have this
part
like i know that part is in me okay how
about this new part this is a weird part
and so to me for example and everybody's
experience is different but because i
had to grow up so fast and provide for
myself since i was really young this is
the first time where i'm like
financially and emotionally depending on
somebody else and it's a [ __ ]
beautiful feeling like where i don't
have to be like yeah oh my god like i
need to [ __ ] struggle and i get to
work and i need to be at 100 all the
time like i still work you know i still
have my job i still have my business
but now having a partner to rely on and
like kind of
take the load together feels amazing
i've never experienced this before oh
yeah i'm so glad that you're
experiencing that it feels like you
start to become a little more balanced
with your life it just feels more like
oh i could take a deep breath and i've
never been able to do that you know i've
never been able to rely on
like a man you know and so now to be
able to rely on my partner it feels
really nice yeah it takes it's like oh i
don't have to like learn how to cook and
do all this stuff and stress out about
it i want to like i want to do these
things yeah i want to like
do my part in the relationship too yeah
and it feels really good that i have
somebody that's like
just let me help you yeah you know like
it feels like he's like let me let's do
this together what's your love language
is it acts of service no actually that's
hiss
that's like the live show
yeah his is like acts of service minus
physical touch okay yeah so oh my god
so funny story it's a learning curve
right so be when we would spend the
night at my house i have a queen bed so
obviously queen bed we're tall you have
to be like this on top of each other we
brought his king bed to the house i
freaking hated that bag yeah because
like because you're separate it's so
easy to go on your own side and so there
was a time so this is what i mean when
you're like so much like it changes yeah
there was a time where like i was like
so emotional i was crying i was like i
freaking hate this bad
you know what it's bad for in feng shui
they say that like a king-sized bed is
bad because there's a divider it's like
two twin size beds right so there's like
a divider in the middle they don't make
like king size frames like the frame is
actually two twins yeah and so like it's
supposed to be bad for dividing your
relationship and when we first got a
king i was stoked because he's big and
he was like you'd make the mattress dent
and i felt like i wasn't getting a good
sleep and when we slept at hotels i'd
sleep so much better but i have a
physical touch like it's pretty good
yeah
i'm like sad that we don't cuddle as
much anymore it's it's definitely
changed the way that it does work
together ladies have you started spring
cleaning yet the carpets need cleaning
the drapes need dusting and you and your
man's lawn needs mowing i'm not talking
about the lawn in the front of the house
spring is sprung and the global leaders
in below the waist grooming have the
best tools for cleaning aisle five in
your pants join the other four million
individuals worldwide who trust
manscaped by going to manscaped.com for
20 off and free shipping with the code
mood i gifted quite a few products from
manscape to my husband steve green
and i can tell you firsthand the lawn
has never looked nicer the statues on
the lawn look much bigger as well i also
got him the plow 2.0 which is the
perfect razor for the finest shave on
his face but also
ladies if you want to steal this for
your legs it's kind of a game changer
legs have also never been smoother the
start of spring also marks the start of
testicular cancer awareness month in
april manscaped is committed to raising
awareness for the most common form of
cancer in men aged 15 to 35 and giving
support to fighters survivors and
families impacted by testicular cancer
as part of their we save balls
initiative have them smell oh so fresh
and so clean this spring with the shave
you want for both of you get 20 off plus
free shipping with the code mood at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with code mood at manscape.com
out with the old grooming habits and in
with the new with manscaped so have you
ever browsed an incognito mode it's
probably not as incognito as you think
and why would it be chances are the
browsers you're using has made its
fortune by tracking your movements
online and what do these big tech
companies say when they're called out
for collecting user data incognito does
not mean invisible so how do you
actually make yourself as invisible as
possible online you use expressvpn like
i do i use it for shopping
trying to get you know bypass ads and
weird things on sites turns out that
even in incognito mode your online
activity still gets tracked and data
brokers still get to buy and sell your
data one of these data points is your ip
address data harvesters use your ip to
uniquely identify you and your location
but with expressvpn your connection gets
rerouted through an encrypted server and
your ip address is masked every time you
connect to expressvpn you get a random
ip address shared by many other
expressvpn customers that makes it
harder for third parties to identify you
or harvest your data best of all
expressvpn is super easy to use no
matter what device you're on phone
laptop or smart tv all you have to do is
tap one button for instant protection so
if you really want to go incognito and
protect your privacy secure yourself
with the number one rated vpn visit
big
expressvpn.com
and get three extra months for free holy
crap three extra months for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com big mood go to expressvpn.com
big mood to learn more so i talked about
in therapy or whatever and she's like
well talk about it like maybe you guys
can start in the middle of the bed and
then eventually at night if you know one
person wants to go this way the other
this way like it's fine so i talked to
danny about it he's like okay so now we
start in the middle of the day
and then at night you know if somebody
throws an arm here and on there
i just have like one foot touching him
it's unnecessarily huge but
that was part of the learning curve the
other thing is i don't know why but both
of us want to sleep on the edge of the
bed so he's way the [ __ ] over there so
you used to have a king size yeah we
used to have a queen oh and now yeah now
we got a king about like two
two years two and a half years ago yeah
and i love it it's great for sleeping
but for cuddling or like into it it's
physical touch yeah and like i feel like
a queen is like even if you're mad
you're touching yeah
like even if you don't want to be here
you're here yeah yeah
which is what marriage is right like
even if something happens like you're
there like you don't really have the
option to just be like okay i'm leaving
we got a guest room now i'm like i'm
going to that i guess yeah
i'm just kidding we don't do that yeah
but um he does snore really loud and
i've been tempted to go to the guest
room oh my god that is
that that's definitely a thing but
thankfully this is very loud oh earplugs
man so i'm a rock hard sleeper i'm like
i sleep through [ __ ] everything but
if he comes in like at three in the
morning like because sometimes he falls
asleep in his office and he comes back
in and he comes in and it kind of wakes
me up and then he starts snoring i
cannot go back to sleep and i'm like
[ __ ] i would have slept through the
whole night but she ruined it
get him sleeping
while he's snoring i'm like
[ __ ] so what do you do you hear me i
talk [ __ ] to him
and you're like just to his subconscious
you hear me
so how do you handle it um what have you
guys done i i put in headphones and i
like put on some meditation music and
like or a sleep story or something like
that and i can usually go back to sleep
or i masturbate like that that does help
yeah nice um
but yeah i i don't know it's just it's
not that often that he wakes me up
usually i'm pretty good at sleeping and
i love him so much that it's not like i
think that
when partners start to build up
resentment for each other every little
thing could piss you away sure but when
you really love somebody and it's like
you love [ __ ] everything about them
their little flaws are kind of cute yeah
it's just like quirky like like oh
you're stupid loud snore yeah stupid
but it's not like it doesn't it's just
something bad yeah yeah i will say
though having two bathrooms is a game
changer i can never go back oh really
can never go back like we used to share
a bathroom and i think that i would get
extremely irritated from that because he
just leaves his stuff out everywhere and
like you know the toothpaste on the
mirrors and then like the like he leaves
the cap off the toothpaste and when
we're in the shower like
he doesn't i like the if there's glass i
like it to be squeegeed so the hard
water doesn't make the like
stains yeah no he doesn't do that even
though it's a squeegee it could just
start irritating me because i just like
things to be
a certain way because i'm not a very
clean person so if i don't clean right
away it will stay dirty
if someone else is making it dirty then
i definitely won't clean it yeah and
it's just it was that was hard but we
got two bathrooms within the first like
we moved within the first two years of
living together okay so we had two
bathrooms and like i was like whoa this
is like a life changer i don't have to
be irritated right off the bat with you
in the morning yeah yeah um when we
moved into our new house though it has
like this huge
master bathroom that has two his and her
sinks and it has like the way nicer
shower in and i was like [ __ ] we're
gonna have to share a bathroom again in
my bedroom and in your bedroom yes
there's your bedroom um so i kicked him
into your bedroom
but thankfully he likes using the guest
bathroom because um it's more private
there's no windows in there
and with the master there's like you can
see everybody's houses
so he's like yeah he's a never nude you
know i've talked about that and he
doesn't like anyone to see him or maybe
possibly see him
even if it's his wife so
yeah he takes a shower in the bathroom
oh nice yes all right well since you
already started nikki what's going on
with your life oh yeah i guess so i
moved she moved well i moved last time
you heard about me but now it feels like
we're really in it because last time it
was like the holidays and moving like
there's a lot of stuff going on but now
like gina's room is ready stacey's room
is oh yeah everybody's got a room we
have like three different guest beds
that people could stay on i have a
murphy bed yeah
when you pull down yeah you pulled down
yeah actually the mattress on there is
the purple mattress that we are
sponsored by and it is super comfy and
that is why i'm so tempted to stay in
the guests one time i've slept on it
several times so freaking comfortable
anyway we're not doing a purple out
right now but but yeah it's uh my office
is really big and it oh the podcast room
is like all set up now and it feels nice
to have every part of my life separated
whereas before it felt kind of i was
telling stacey this before we started
shooting but it felt like everything was
really cramped like where we're working
from home and we live at home and
everything's in the same area and when
we do the podcast we set it up and we
have to break it down and just a lot of
like extra steps involved and it takes
away from
it's just draining energetically it
takes away from the content of the show
i felt even because by the time we
started i was already tired yeah um but
now it's like everything's set up
everything looks nice and you just turn
on lights and camera and then you're
ready to go and it's just like here you
know where it's like a little studio and
then we leave and that part of the house
we don't even go to that part of the
house it's like a separate wing of the
house
there's a guest room there and the
podcast room and so it's like completely
separated and then everything else is
like in this part of the house and um
and then we have a bar like
a yeah there's a full a full bar
i guess
yeah it feels grown and then i think you
know like how you were saying is
during those years i mean i remember 27
i was not the same person where
everything actually was more like gina
where everything was everywhere and i
had my organized chaos you know it's if
you looked at me it's like oh she has
her life together but then you like see
my house and it's like a [ __ ]
disaster and i have you know cats
everywhere and um i
it's not like i liked living like that
but i didn't know how to do it any other
way i didn't know how to cook and then i
started my tasty tuesday show and i
actually did learn how to cook through
every week doing that show and i'm like
wow i actually can cook meals now
and then the same with like organizing i
was just one day like we moved into our
condo i think that's what it was like
when it's like you have this ownership
you that sense of ownership like oh okay
i'm not renting anymore like this is
mine yeah i'm gonna take care of it and
like do things that make it beautiful
and i got really into organizing and
like making everything aesthetically
pleasing especially the things i didn't
want to do like cleaning like i didn't
want to clean because it just sucked and
it's still still not my favorite but
yeah now i have like cute cleaning
supplies and like everything's like
organized so i'm like okay on my
cleaning day like i have the system and
it's just really easy and it makes it
fun for me yeah and i didn't realize
that you could like make something fun
and so
my kitchen is like there's always
storage and everything's in the clear
containers with the labels on it and i
make my oatmeal in the morning and it's
like here's the oatmeal here's the brown
sugar and i feel like uh like a solid
wife now
probably going into that next like phase
of maybe having children we've been
discussing but
i told
baby i know right i'm getting a baby
um but i think i feel like i could
handle it yeah whereas before i felt
like oh that just be too chaotic
i do feel like we want to have like one
year in las vegas before yeah and
children and enjoy it so okay this is my
gap year and and same thing that that
you were talking about where i've always
been like i need to work work work work
work because like oh i'm holding the
whole ship together yeah but now steve's
really come into his own where he's like
taken over a lot of the workload and
um making a lot of money with his
investments that he put into place five
years ago and it's all like kind of
coming together now and and so i do feel
like for the first time
i can just like ease off the gas pedal
and like chill and it's really weird
because i've never had that before i've
always felt like i had to go go
and i
kind of felt like and this is it sounds
kind of mean but it's not mean i really
love my friends i just kind of felt like
i had to hang out before to like keep
relationships and like keep them
feeling loved and like knowing that like
hey i care about you and so this is me
showing that but i felt
like it was taking away from all the
stuff i wanted to do because i was like
i was in work mode and now i have to
like
hang out and it was really hard for me
and now i actually feel like i can be
present and i can hang out yeah and i
actually enjoy it and it's not like a
social obligation anymore i just
genuinely
can be hanging out with people and i've
never felt that way and it does feel
like
there's this balance
coming together where i'm like wow like
a social life that's new and like
i have like
there's lakes that you walk around and
like it feels like that's all like
beautiful and i can just enjoy each
moment instead of like okay check check
check you know i got my exercise got my
meditation got into the yeah okay now
yeah yeah
it's like i like it
what's your uh tv star like uh like gina
bro life has been wild since yes update
every time i see a picture of you you're
like in a dracula outfit
prince junior there's something going on
so okay wait before you go explain to me
what you do because i just know that
you're on tv but i just like i know her
i don't know what she's doing but i know
her
i actually wanted to make a video about
this too uh so i am now the host of g4
tv
uh g4 tv was a tv channel back in the
early 2000s
uh that was solely dedicated to video
games and comics and all things nerd so
i grew up watching it wow specifically a
show called
uh attack of the show the one with
olivia munn
she started on that show yeah so olivia
munn started there and so
i remember coming home from school every
day and like
watching that because i was like oh my
god it's
a network about what i love video games
and then there's a woman talking about
video games and i was like that's so
cool i never had anyone talk about video
games too or anyone that seemed
interested especially a girl you know so
i would come home every day after school
in middle school and just watch it in
elementary school too and i remember
thinking man i wish i could be on that
show one day yeah yeah so
uh now that we're in the middle of the
renaissance of video games and uh it's
become like a professional sport and
stuff like that and now it's the perfect
time so comcast uh decided we want to
bring it back
so they brought back g4 tv with the old
legacy host like the host that i used to
watch growing up
i idolized
and they
put out casting calls
and then uh in end of 2020 i got an
email from a casting director or agent
whatever saying hey g4tv wants you on
their show and i was like you [ __ ]
liar
this is a scam so i didn't respond for
like two days
and then they're like hey following up
we really want to meet you i'm like okay
whatever
and then
okay let's see what happens so we set up
a zoom meeting because this was during
quarantine
and uh in the zoom meeting there were
executives
and one of which dan martin said yeah i
worked on the old g4 and i was like okay
so i googled it on the side and i was it
was real
oh no
i'm not wearing pants
[ __ ] like i did not take this seriously
yeah
and long story short um
one day when we were at our trip to big
bear yeah i got the email i remember in
the evening while we're all drinking and
i was like oh my god and then
after like five months of auditioning
and meetings and stuff they're like we
want you
in our network and it's amazing and then
so such good timing too because you were
at a renewal with the other company you
were working with and you were kind of
like i don't really want to but i don't
know and like what am i going to do and
then this came through and it was like
all right yeah problem solved the timing
was crazy i was going through like that
crazy drama yeah
you know you all know about that
and then there are many tick tocks on
google docs about this yeah
uh and then so
not only am i part of the network i'm on
the show that i dreamed of being on a
specific show
so um you manifested this i did i
manifested it all those years of cheeto
dust fingers i know
gracie foreign gaming consoles yeah and
then but as of recently
uh i am now on a second show so now i
have a second permanent show wow they
haven't said the invite to party one
yeah what is that one about so this show
is called invitational party and we're
playing dungeons and dragons what live
[ __ ] yeah this is some real hardcore
nerd [ __ ]
and
we so god how do i explain this to you
it's it's uh have you guys ever read
like the choose your own adventure book
yes where you like oh if you want to do
this go to page this if you want to go
with this yes that was that kind of nerd
yeah hi nibbler come here
come here we're telling stories can you
get attention what do you want goodness
sorry we're getting interrupted by a cat
he's very demanding i know he's there
you go okay there everyone loves you you
just want to show off her
good job
so um
we're playing dungeons and dragons and
it's basically there's one he's he's the
game master and he is
this man named b dave and he is an
incredible incredible storyteller he
tells you okay
uh stacy nikki you walk into
a tavern and you see this giant uh
magician blah blah blah what do you want
to do and nikki you can do you can say
whatever you want you can be like i want
to bang him something yeah that's what i
was thinking yeah stacy be like i want
to fight him whatever and then he has to
go along with it and he tells you okay
this is what you do and that's what
happens but he also has to build the
world and story for you and he's like he
he like grew up on shakespeare and he
was just incredible so i i had a guest
appearance uh and i did a guest
appearance and i fell in love with the
game yeah like absolutely did you you
played the game before
i played it for like two hours before
back in 2014 like you knew how it worked
but you weren't like yeah group because
i have my brother-in-law both of them um
brother-in-law's they them and their
wives uh have a group they play dungeons
and dragons like so cute every freaking
sunday and my and you know what's funny
if steve was butt hurt that he wasn't
invited
and he was like i'm gonna throw my own
dungeon a dragon
hooker's back yeah um
so i i did a guest appearance and i fell
in love with it and i harassed the
executive producers i'm like i want i
want back i want permanent yeah i want
permanent so bad so they brought me on
for like a second episode
and then i screamed at them again like i
want permanent i want to roll i'm like
when gina wants something yeah no and
then so
uh i got the phone call because
they were like you did really well for
your first time hi kid
and there i got the phone call they were
like we want to personally like i mean
to officially invite you to be a
full-time cast member wow so now i'm on
two tv shows
yeah
and it's really fun because it's like
when people ask me what i'm doing i'm
like i play dungeons and dragons for a
[ __ ] living
and it really makes me because you have
to play a character so i have to really
work on my acting and improv yeah it's
super fun that's awesome um so now i'm
on two shows which i'm really happy
about if you're sleeping on a terrible
mattress your sleep will be terrible
it's that simple that's why i recommend
sleeping on a purple mattress it's not
rocket science but it is rocket
sleep to the to the space that you need
to have good dreams yeah nailed it
that's because only purple mattresses
have the gel flex grid it's a super
stretchy ultra squishy material that
adapts and flexes around the pressure
points and it doesn't retain heat so if
you have like a sweaty husband like i do
i mean or maybe i don't i don't know i'm
not gonna not try to throw them under
the bus but maybe i do
this really helps to not have that those
night sweats that you often get and
doesn't you know overheat your body it's
great the gel flex grid is amazingly
supportive for your back and legs while
cushioning your shoulders neck and hips
no matter how you sleep this is actually
what i personally love it for i have a
terrible back i don't know why but
basically almost any bed i sleep in i'm
just bound to have terrible back pain
except for the purple mattress the
purple measures really conforms to like
if i want to sleep on my side it
conforms to my little like bony
shoulders i don't know i don't know
science again i'm just looking for good
sleep and purple mattress has given it
to me getting a great night's sleep
starts with having a great mattress get
a purple mattress go to purple.com big
mood 10 and use code big mood 10. for a
limited time you can get 10 off any
order of 200 or more that's purple.com
big mood 10 code big mood 10 for 10 off
any order of 200 or more purple.com big
move 10 promo code big mood 10 terms
apply fresh from san diego california
comes the only sunglasses brand i'm ever
going to wear ever again i'm talking
about blenders i wear and you're going
to be just as hooked when you see how
awesome these shades are i got the madam
x because i really like cat eyes it fits
my round face they're perfect to wear
when i'm driving they're so comfortable
and they match all my outfits especially
when i want to look badass chase fisher
started blenders by selling his beachy
shades out of his backpack while
doubling as a surf instructor on pacific
beach his goal was to create an
adventurous mid-price eyewear option
with the same cool factor as other
leading styles unlike expensive big
brand shades that you've probably lost
or smashed in the past i've lost a lot
blenders are actually affordable so
you're not going to cry as much when the
inevitable happens blender's team of
in-house designers are constantly coming
out with new styles from orange
polarized wraparounds tortoise shell
frames with purple lenses to classic
gold arms on black lens and it's not
just sunglasses blenders has
prescription glasses readers and blue
light glasses like the ones that i wear
when i stream as well as a snow
collection with goggles and accessories
live life and forward motion with
blenders today to score 15 off your
blender's purchase visit
blunderseyewear.com and enter the promo
code big mood vip that's
blenderseyewear.com code big mood vip
for 15 off blenders rocked with pride
worldwide i feel like this past year the
past couple of months has been the
universe has been throwing curveballs at
me and going nuts yeah uh i got cheated
on yeah that's so fun right from a
different person so this was a person in
my past um it was because not the google
doc person that's another one um this
was a lawyer i was dating and we decided
to try again and we exclusively decided
to be monogamous yeah yeah as one does
yes one does apparently i was the only
one that signed that agreement you know
oh did he put the doc did he as a lawyer
right you know the fine print in there
only i can cheat only yeah
so uh i found out in november oh no
december
and i had it was crazy like i won't go
into like full details but i found out
in december
and i got in contact with the girl
and i found out that they had slept with
each other back in july you're stupid to
cheat on gina cause she will find out
and she will find out all the details
and information of everyone that this
person's ever been with
but i do have to say you would be stupid
to cheat on gina period period like
she's amazing yeah you're amazing you're
beautiful you have you're on two tv
shows dumbass yeah you're like the
coolest girl and sweetest angel i've
ever known
it's just we have to know that this was
a him thing and like a lack of security
thing you know because i think if it was
just based on who you are you wouldn't
get cheated on yeah it has to be him it
was it was a it was a very strange like
the thing is i wasn't i didn't like
super cry ball hard heartbreak because i
kind of
i kind of knew you kind of felt like you
always feel like yeah you know women's
intuition is really strong i kind of
knew and so i got in contact with the
girl and i was like so when you guys
meet she goes july
he hit on me and i was like oh my god i
was recovering from surgery i it was my
birthday and i remember he was begging
for me to go out with him this one night
but i couldn't and he went and he was
making out with her what the [ __ ] yeah
and then um uh i found out because my
friends walked into a restaurant and saw
them together and they sent a picture to
me they're like isn't that isn't that
your dude i was like yes it is
and then so thanks for the picture yeah
she's got eyes and ears everywhere yeah
so amazing
it's me yeah i have people everywhere
what are you doing with this girl yeah
so i texted him
and i was like hey where are you at he
goes oh i'm just you know getting high
with my roommate and you know we're just
hanging out chilling i was like yeah
and then so we facetimed i was like cool
cool cool so who's this girl she's so
cute with her bangs
and how old is she only 24. aren't you
like 31 like i had all her information
already
um and then so it was it's been crazy
because i feel like the universe with
this new year really and i was talking
to all my friends and my friends were
going through it too like the universe
is really cleaning house it's like
polarized it's like girls here's some
[ __ ] that you want oh sorry no worries
it's here's some [ __ ] that you really
wanted so that you're gonna be so
excited about but i gotta kill all this
other stuff yeah so like you're gonna
have to grieve and like mourn some of
this [ __ ] but and it really sucks but
yeah it is a clean house thing where
yeah that stuff has to kind of die off
and kind of go
that way yeah it's crazy like dealing
because like after
going through the process because i've
made it a point to stay single not see
anyone to
heal and learn and i realized i was
dating a full-blown narcissist yeah like
back-to-back though back-to-back so now
you kind of
know a pattern to look for so that
that's not it doesn't happen again yeah
like you stay single and do your thing
you're [ __ ] crushing it out there
you're having fun the time of your life
it'll just come to you in a way where
you're like like if the right guy comes
you'll [ __ ] know yeah and when he
starts if there's any red flags you'll
know that too
um it was it really taught me a lot
about like sometimes you're being too
patient and sometimes you're being
[ __ ] nice
it's it's at the expense of your own
happiness and respect girl this is all i
talk about on tick tock yeah i'm like
you got to be a [ __ ] and you got to be
high maintenance in the beginning
if they can deal with that then they get
the angel that you are you know but you
can't handle me at my [ __ ]
well and not even like be disrespectful
you know but like set the standard up
here because wherever you set the
standard it's gonna fall inevitably yeah
when we're in love we become softer
look at me cooking and cleaning yeah
it's true
but it's true like you got to start with
the highest of standards you know and
like treat yourself for the person you
are and you realize all that you are
because maybe sometimes you don't
realize all you bring to the table yeah
you know because yeah this guy was this
and this guy was that but i'm like but
you're you
you know like
he he didn't impress me i'm like work
harder i remember thinking at one point
i was like stacy would be so would be so
disappointed because this fool was like
he was like
for a lawyer that came from a rich
family he was always like hey so i paid
for the last meal can you get this one
oh gosh yeah you can't be cheap too i
know like you can't be cheap i know 80
people right now commenting that are
like gina i will give you the world yeah
i will buy you chanel bags i will take
you on trips you know i was stuck in
that like no i can fix him stage i know
yeah you know or like if we ride through
the hard times whatever but then i
started realizing like
this why am i putting up with this like
why am i putting up with someone that
throws [ __ ] that throws a tantrum that
screams that like narcissists are really
charming that's why in the beginning
yeah
they're little children and then i
remember like and then now that i look
at it like there was resentment there
from him too that's why he wanted to
bring me down like i remember he would
go through because he was my lawyer also
and he would go through my contracts be
like and see my brain how much you're
right he's like why did i even go to law
school like it was a lot of little
things here and there
competitive with you yeah competition
yeah and see that doesn't make like a
man that loves you is gonna be like [ __ ]
yeah and we're gonna fight for more yeah
yeah we're gonna get you more even if
i'm not making this or that or whatever
like
like that protectiveness it's not just
financially it's in all aspects whatever
they can do for you they're gonna do for
you because they want to make your life
easier yeah and they know that if they
help you win they're winning too like
it's a team
exactly so it was pretty wild like going
back on everything it's like wow that
was a terrible person yeah
but you needed to go through it i needed
to
i think what really
really um
made me
realize i was like okay this is not okay
was well
um
a couple things like one time i was
going through a massive depression and
stuff my grandmother just had a stroke
and he comes over he goes hey so i
noticed that you're really sad lately
i'm like yeah you know this isn't this
going on he goes well can you not oh
what because you know we're supposed to
be hanging out and having a good time
he's a psychopath he's a psycho he's a
psychopath it's not it's kind of killing
my mood yeah like you're grieving your
grand grandma right now
it was wild he's not even dead okay so
like yeah smile all right i remember
halloween he thought i locked him out of
my house here but i didn't because i
went through the front door unlocked it
he was like banging on the door with my
with his fake axe that he had for his
halloween costume my sister was here too
it was three in the morning he was
banging woke up the whole house
and screaming like did you lock me out
this is [ __ ] unacceptable and when i
opened the door he actually hit me with
his backs
i was like oh she hurt me and he goes i
don't give a [ __ ] what and then i was
like he woke up my whole house he's like
i don't give a [ __ ] and that's when i
realized okay we're done yeah like this
is that is not okay
yeah and then it could have easily just
like i said where it starts it's only
gonna go down from there so
he was already verbally verbally abusive
and so it was only a matter of time
before yeah it started off as an
accident and then it's like i'm pushing
you oh it's just a push
and then it's like
yeah yeah and then it's like he's
actually like being physically abusive
so i'm glad you got out yeah so that's
when i really realized like this is not
okay and also this is when everything
was taken off like the premiere of my tv
show i'm finally on national television
and i was like why am i on national
television
the premiere i'm watching i'm so happy
and then we argued that night yeah you
know so that's when i was like i'm still
like he doesn't want you to have any
happiness i think he wants to suck out a
lot exactly happiness so i was already
kind of like slowly kind of phasing him
out and then that's when i found out he
cheated on me i was like thanks for that
yeah that made it easy yeah that made it
easy for me
um so now i'm like happier than ever
because
no boy drama
i'm completely over that yeah i have two
tv shows now and it's like this is nice
like this is peaceful yes
stay in that zone for a while yeah for a
long while or like the attitude of like
i could do this forever yeah and i don't
need anything else last week i met ferdi
prince junior yeah he's beautiful you
drooled i saw a clip of you drooling
yeah he was amazing apparently he's a
giant dungeons and dragons player this
week we had danny trejo like it's it's
like it's been fun i'm telling you yeah
all the hot ones are nerds
truly so much truly you know so it's
been a really rewarding
ride so far
and i like i finally feel like i'm in
the place where i want to be like it
seems like it for sure yeah this is an
outsider looking in like i'm like dude
you're thriving i'm happy for you yeah
it just seems like you're in your
element
like this is where you were she was
always meant to be yeah yeah yeah yeah
like because gina waking up at 7 00 am
but happy about it yeah that's wild that
if you told gina to from two years ago
yeah she'd be like hey you're gonna wake
up at seven you're gonna be stopped
you're on drugs
are we high in the future
so that's what's been going on and i'm
happy
that's great yeah that's so awesome and
i love all the outfits you wear
dude i go into somebody somebody
actually worded it perfectly on twitter
they said you basically get to be in you
get paid to be in a never-ending frat
party yeah and it's true because i go
into filming every week not knowing what
the hell we're going to do
um so the show that i'm on attack of the
show it's
have you ever seen like tosh.0 where
they like go through all like all the
viral videos and they laugh about it or
like okay so
uh
g4 basically kind of started that
attacking the show start about started
that back in the 2000s and we're like a
variety show of like we're going through
all the internet videos all the
everything in pop culture
we have like
guests from like wwe wrestling we have
freddie prince jr we have all that and
then it's just a funny show we do
challenges
uh like for thanksgiving we had a a
gravy death ray that our prop guy built
were strapped to a table
and we have to play pictionary if every
wrong guess that you get the laser moves
higher up on oh my gosh it's just a
crazy party every week and it's think of
it like uh i've been trained for this
with jquery party yeah for like the last
time i was just thinking that like jacob
party is like the light version of this
exactly
so it's i it's it's every week it's just
a party and i play video games and
dungeons and dragons for a living that's
so fun so do you still do your twitch
stream or yeah
wow how do you manage this tonight
jobs weekends or at night when i can't
sleep you know i just stream because
then she's also doing big mood like one
time two years yeah this is the most
i've ever had to conduct like do it but
all your work's fun at least it's fun
yeah you enjoy it yeah yeah i i truly
can can i can truly honestly say now
that i really [ __ ] love what i do
that's awesome everything that i have i
love it it fulfills you it's like
there's a different you feel a
difference like the things that you the
work that you don't like to do it's
draining but the work that you do have
to do you come home and you're still
pumped yeah exactly like i can't wait to
go back tomorrow yeah and then like i'm
part of a company where it's like
i we all really do look out for each
other and it's really sweet we check in
on each other you know like
uh and we want just everyone to succeed
and our uh so this is
although it is very fun it is also very
corporate we're a part of comcast you
know
so it's a very corporate job i have to
clock in oh no you know like it's weird
to get lunch you know yeah
um but
for
for something that's so corporate
it's so
also very the higher ups really listen
to us you know like and
if i say like i really want to be more
part of this more they're like yeah okay
let's put it in there it seems like a
very collaborative open type of
environment yeah that's really cool i
also thought it was so such a mind mind
trip when like you and cassim were on
the same show together because it was
like two separate
worlds of my internet life yeah like you
guys are now on a show together yeah
it's so cool because like yeah i never
thought of those two personalities
gelling but that makes so much sense
yeah it's very strange because like it
brought very odd people from different
parts of entertainment together like
kasim
i've heard of him throughout all my
years in youtube but i never really
watched youtube videos but i knew the
name casamg kasmg and now he's my
co-host on the same show yeah and i
think because i didn't
associate him with like video games but
he was like he did play a lot of video
games just in private he wasn't like a
public game
and uh and then he would do the comic
cons every year yeah so i'm like oh yeah
i guess that is like his jam too and
then with you it's more it was more
obvious because you've been a gamer and
yeah i'm like yeah you both are funny
you both are like
engaged in in video games you love the
comic nerd world it just makes so much
sense i had no idea that he was into
video games either and then like when i
saw him i was like you're in this too
he's like yeah
we just signed i was like holy crap so
i've been introduced to so many like
remarkable people
and it's it's
it's like a i uh
i and i want to i want to
grow and learn so more about them yeah
and i know you're taking like an improv
class and like you're just growing fun
uh you'd kill it at that i mean you do
kill it at that point yeah you're
already good at it but to even just tone
that more is like it's [ __ ] awesome i
didn't know what yes and was and then i
learned about it and now i hear it
everywhere yes and we have to go now yes
yes
now because we're running out of time
but
thanks for catching up with us yeah we
i've missed you guys i've been gone for
a few episodes i've missed you guys so
much go follow stacy on all her [ __ ] you
can find out about her wedding journey
actually by the time this comes out
it'll be even closer to the day so you
can see her
she's good yeah she's got jewelry so
check out her jewelry we'll put all of
your info in the description thank you
but just in case for the audio listeners
what's your instagram so that they
didn't follow my instagram stacy the
support guy if you don't know how to
spell that just type in stacy diaz and
you'll find me everywhere yeah uh and
make sure you guys like this video give
us a thumbs up five stars like us uh
make us feel good about ourselves yeah
please boost our self-esteem we love you
guys we love you until then bye peace
[Music]